updated renewable energy and efficiency  targets will be put to the vote in  Strasbourg 32% of the EU energy needs  should come from renewables by 2030  keeping Europe on track for its climate  change goals members vote on new rules  to reduce the cost of calls and texts  within Europe effectively improving  consumer protection and increasing  transparency the German Chancellor  Angela Merkel will debate the future of  Europe with Parliament Parliament will  announce the winner of the 2018 lux film  prize the three finalists are Styx woman  at war and the documentary film the  other side of everything members vote on  tougher rules to protect rail passenger  rights similar to those for airline  passengers the proposals include  doubling the compensation for delayed or  cancelled trains  [Music]